All right.
So last time we were talking about the
investor game and this was a coordination
game and we learned some things.
There's been a recall from
the things we learned too.
I can highlight them events.
One thing we learned was
that communication can help
in a coordination game.
So I forget who it was, but someone down
here who was disappeared, uh, was, uh,
it was our Jimmy Stewart character
and helped coordinate you on a better
equilibrium simply by suggesting
what you should do. And this,
there's two lessons here.
One is this is very different
from the prisoner's dilemma.
So we learned the very
first time it doesn't,
the prisoner's dilemma
communication per se won't help.
But in the coordination problem,
which could be just as serious
socially as a prisoner's dilemma in a
coordination problem,
it may well help.
And the reason it helps is you're trying
to coordinate onto a nash equilibrium.
And one way to think about now she
equilibria is that they are self enforcing
agreements.
So it provided on believed that everyone
else is going to go along with this
agreement. Then, uh, everyone
in fact, well, all right.
I want to make another slightly more
philosophical remark associated with this
and it's to do with
the idea of leadership.
So leadership is kind of a big word
that you see written probably too often
these days in too many newspaper
articles and it comes up in too many Yale
classes and I don't claim to know
anything about me to ship. All right.
Bought and under they get game
theory is going to contribute.
Anything to understanding
about leadershape bots.
One thing we can do is tell you
where leadership may help. All right?
And then the coordination game,
we are where the,
the idea is to try and get people to
coordinate on a particular equilibria
rather than an another
equilibria or worse.
Still all just be uncoordinated
entirely in those kinds of games.
Leadership can help tremendously in
little bit of leadership can help
tremendously.
So these games,
these coordination games are
games where there is a scope
for leadership.
And just to see that, uh, in
a very simple example, again,
we didn't need a such a complicated
example is the one we looked at last time.
You could imagine a game,
a really trivial coordination game,
which looked like this.
All right? One one zero, zero
is there a zero one, one?
And clearly in this game,
what matters is coordinating,
you either want to coordinate on Aarp
left or you want to coordinate on down,
right? You don't want to end up, uh, to d.
You don't want to end up uncoordinated
on down, left or upright.
Everyone see that? So in this
game, if you just played it,
it's quite likely going
to end up uncoordinated.
But if a little bit of leadership can
say, okay, let's make sure this is where,
this is where we coordinate all, let's
make sure this is where we coordinate.
All right?
So this matters a lot and I don't want to
overplay the social importance of this,
but go back a couple of years to what
was happening in the aftermath of Katrina
and realize how important,
how,
how bad things get when
things fail to be coordinated.
All right.
One other remark before we leave this
in the game we played last time in the
investment game.
One feature of that game was that the
more you thought other people were going
to invest, the more you wanted to invest
that, right? The more you thought, oh,
he'll going to invest,
the more likely you are going to invest
and he'd go back to the time before that.
We talked about this partnership
game and the partnership game.
You were contributing efforts to a joint
project. It could have been a law firm,
it could have been working in a study
group on a homework assignment and that
game, if you remember what the
best response is, look like,
okay,
they look like this or this was the effort
of player one and this was the effort
of player to this was this was the best
response of player one and this was the
best response of planets to this game.
Also has the feature that the more effort,
the other person, the more
the other person does, the
more you want to do, right?
The more efforts your partner
provides into this projects,
the more effort you want
to provide in this project.
And was when they introduced
a bit of jargon here,
these games in which the
more the other person does,
the more I want to do these are called
Games of strategic compliments, right?
These are games of strategic compliments,
strategic
how funds.
All right?
So both the investment game and
the game with the partnership,
the partnership from game or
games or treated components,
we can call the strategies
strategic compliments.
And we'll come back to this
later on today. All right,
so before we leave coordination games,
I want to look at another one and a little
bit more complicated one perhaps that
we mentioned briefly last time.
Uh, so we're looking at that.
We'll look at an play another game and
we'll call this game going to the movies.
All right.
So I always regard one purpose of this
class to help hapless Yale students in
their dating strategies. Uh, that seems
like a good thing to do. Uh, and, uh,
how many of you just don't, uh, we
didn't need to show the camera on this,
but how many of you are econ majors?
There's a lot of people who probably
did a lot of help with our dating
strategies. Right, right, right. Okay.
So the idea of this game is a couple
is going to meet up at the movies and,
uh, well let's have a
look at the movies, uh,
concerned here and we'll draw
the three possible movies.
Okay.
All right. Well the is we're
going to look at our, um,
the born Alto Mason
and the,
uh,
movie called Good Shepherd
and a movie called Snow White.
Okay.
And I'll explain the game
more detail in a second.
I used to be in the old days before I
had kids, I could list off for 15, uh,
current movies and help you a bit more
with your dating strategy by giving you
instant movie reviews.
But now I have kids,
I get to see precisely two movies a year.
Uh,
and the toolkit moves I've got
to see this year where, uh,
the Bourne ultimatum and, uh, the good
shepherd. And now I think about it,
both of those have Matt Damon
in it and my wife chose both.
So maybe I need to work out some more.
So just to give you some
idea about how many,
how many of you saw Bourne ultimatum?
Quite a lot of you. This is a movie.
It has pretty good action.
Virtually no plots.
A basic lesson of this movie is a,
uh, if you, if you take home lesson,
it's that all spy is a psychos
or something like that.
And then I how many so good shepherd,
a lot of used to that as well.
That's actually a pretty good,
it has a lot of plots and no actions.
It's helping other way around. And
uh, the basic lesson of this movie is,
and nobody knew this already, uh,
everyone at Yale, at the technical yell,
everyone at Yale is a spy. And
by the way, also a psychos.
And the third movie is, um, is Snow White,
which I haven't gone out to see. But, uh,
my,
uh,
four year old daughter has seen on
24 of the last 27 lates on video.
Uh, and this movie, um, I don't know if
I'd recommend it that much. Uh, it's, um,
as I'm being too PC,
but I'm not convinced that for
the modern woman hanging around,
waiting for your printers to come is
really a good strategy. Um, by the way,
for those of you who are, you are, but
if you were ordering that strategy,
I'm gonna get in trouble.
Then mind if you're in that strategy,
take it from a Brit. Most printers are as
dumb as toast, not worth way. All right,
so let's,
let's put the payoffs in here.
So the idea here is that these
people are going to move.
They're going to meet at the movie. I'm
going to go, went to a movie, and they've,
they've decided to go to the,
to the criterion or the local movie house.
And there were these three movies showing
and they're all excited to this movie
excepts being economics majors
and not very good at dancing.
They have to gotten to,
to tell each other which movie
they're actually going to go to.
Aren't they going to meet in the,
you know, in there on the back row?
Probably and uh, um, uh, but
they're not, they're not telling us,
uh,
which movie there's a problem and it's
put in the payoffs and we'll put in the
payoffs that roughly I think would
correspond to my preference is,
and we'll talk about it,
what these preferences mean in a second.
Okay.
So here we go.
So minus one,
minus one zero minus one
zero minus minus two.
So here are the preferences for these
movies of player one and player two.
And you can see from these preferences,
I have heard from these payoffs that uh,
the,
the best thing for player
one is for both players,
both people to meet and go to the Bourne
ultimatum. This is the action movie.
All right, so, so as not to be
sexist, I assume this is the,
this is the she and this is the heat.
So she would like to go and see a Matt
Damon beat people up and coordinate that,
how her favorite thing, uh, and she gets
nothing if they fail to coordinate, uh,
and uh, so on and so forth. Uh,
her second choice is at a managed to
coordinate at Matt Damon being a gale spy.
Uh, all right. And then she really
doesn't want to go and see snow white.
And the worst thing of all,
actually this is for both buyers,
the worst thing of all is to coordinate
it snow white because then you've got to
talk about it afterwards at coffee. All
right? And some of the other person,
same thing exactly except that uh,
he would rather meet at a of
the good shepherd. Uh, you know,
since he's a Yale Guy,
he probably thinks of themselves as the
Matt Damon character that'll perhaps
knock coming, but, and uh, you know,
failing that you'd like to coordinate
at the Bourne ultimatum. But again,
the disaster is to fail to coordinating,
go to the different movies. All right,
so these are the provinces. What can
we, what can we tell immediately if,
if any of you are stuck in this situation,
what can you tell immediately about
this, about this game? What God wants?
An easy first step is get the,
the guy in red here
snowy, it was snow white is dominated by
both players. Good. So for both plans,
for both planners,
Snow White is a Dominique is strategy.
So both players having taken this class,
I told you I was helping with her dating,
but right.
So both planners will realize that they
shouldn't at least not going to Snow
White, is that right? Right.
Great animation, but not pat.
Not perhaps a good date movie.
So, uh, it's gone. All right,
everyone see that?
So that leaves us just
with these two options, uh,
the two Matt Damon movies,
Bourne ultimatum and good shepherd.
And here are the remaining payoffs. And
let's, let's see how we play this out. So,
so again, let's, let's pick on some
people. I don't want to pick on somebody.
Okay.
It kind of goes on as well.
All right.
All right. So, okay. Okay. So we would
pick on somebody that, uh, when do you,
the person who Alec picked
on you understand up.
Okay. And your name is, say
again, loudly, Nina, Nina,
and enter the shout out to run his
Aina. And Carl, did you pick on a guy?
Nina. Nina. Okay. Nina. I'm
sorry, Nina and car you get, get,
get your guy to stand up there.
And your name is David. David.
So do you know each other? No. No,
you're okay. So your practical on a date.
So this is all right. All right.
So Nina's preferences mean
his preferences. I'll play
a one's preferences here.
So she,
uh,
her best thing now is to successfully
meet David at the Bourne ultimatum.
And David's preferences are a payer.
Twos preferences are his favorite thing
is to successfully meet at the good
shepherd. And why didn't you
write down, uh, a second, uh,
on the corner of a new pad?
What it is you're going to choose to do
with my tas watching cause you really
can't cheat.
All right.
Both written down. All right. We have good
luck here. We go to a good look at them.
So we just embarrassment of it. We looked
at them already, I guess. Okay. Okay. So,
uh, Nina's a shout out to the crowd.
What it is, you've went where it is.
You've chosen to go or an ultimatum,
but what else makes him and David,
why don't you choose to go?
I also put down born
ultimately I can think in the
coordinator. That's attention.
Very good.
Alright.
I don't,
I don't know what this test,
I don't know what this tells us
about David and Nina, but don't, no,
nothing off the hook quite
yet. So now, um, that was good.
We managed to coordinate all the way.
I think we can all see that
we might not have done right.
We all see we might not have
done it. All right. Let's, um,
let's try some communication in this game.
We said the coordination games are
helped by communication. All right,
so let's imagine we're playing
the game again. Once again,
you're going to the movies. Once again,
these are the first one didn't happen.
So you didn't have somebody
that was council that night.
Someone had a bad cold or something.
And then you are about to go off on a
Friday night to see these movies and, uh,
let's allow some communication ahead
of time. So, so David, uh, uh, uh,
he brought it to get, Oh, you know,
you realize you've got
this coordination problem,
so you phone meaner up and
you can say whatever you like.
So what would you say to Nealon?
Uh,
it looks like you want to
go to Bourne ultimatum.
Okay. Uh, I'd rather I'd rather go
and if you're going to be stubborn,
I'd rather go see the board ultimately
with you then, uh, then
not knock on a date. Okay.
So here's another clue. Stubborn
is not a good first date. Right.
All right. But okay. So Nina, what
would you say in response to that?
I'll go to Bourne ultimatum.
Alright. Alright. All right.
So write down where you're
going to do this time.
Okay.
All right. And Nina, what did you do for
an ultimatum? David Bourne ultimatum.
They're still managing to
coordinate, but you can. Okay.
So, so thank you. Thank you.
Thank for this couple.
I was giving a round of applause.
We may come back and pick out you later
on in the course, but we'll, we'll,
we'll leave it for now.
All right. So in this case,
could look at the
communication worked alright,
but how am I liked him thinking
that the communication isn't,
isn't such an instant solution as
it was in the game we saw last time,
this games a little bit harder to
get communication to work. And why?
I mean is, is that right? First of all.
So what's, what's the problem here?
Why is this a slightly more difficult
game? Let's get the handy a second.
Why is this a more difficult
game to attain coordination
and um, yeah, that's it.
That's the case you get.
Can You
well I know, hang on a second. Hold on a
second. That's a good, that's a good one.
That's, let's start with
that. What are the national,
what are the Nash
Equilibrium in this game?
What are the Nash Equilibrium this game?
Uh, somebody that says pick on somebody.
Just pick on anybody. K. Yeah. What
are the Nash Equilibrium? This game?
Both players doing Bourne ultimatum
in both players doing good shepherd.
All right. So, so in fact if
we, if we check the notion,
the magic whatever in this game,
the Nash Equilibria,
and you can check that they are in fact
best responses are both people doing the
Bourne ultimatum or both
people doing the good shepherd.
And the reason for that is if the other
person's going to go to Bourne ultimatum,
I want to do that. And if the other
person is going to go to good shepherd,
I wanted to do that. So these are both
Nash Equilibria. That isn't too much.
The problem.
That was true last time as well.
There were two well
coordinated Nash Equilibria.
The one of them was better than the Alba,
which the tricky thing here, what's,
what's the extra tray?
Yeah. Somebody uh, yeah. Uh,
it's real camera. It's built
with Mike on this side. Sorry.
It was me. There was a handout that,
yeah, Yup, Yup, Yup. Go, go, go, go.
Yeah, you go stand up. Great.
Prefers a different Nash equilibrium.
All so,
so unlike the other game that the two
dead zone was a coordination game.
If we saw so far,
we're really pure coordination problems.
That right there were pure
coordination problems.
There was no conflict at all in, in the
case of the investor game last week,
every plan preferred one equilibrate
to the other, right? In the game.
I just put up this a triggered example.
It didn't really Massa which
equilibrium we played here,
we just wanted to play an equilibrium.
Is that right? Is that right? But here,
there's a potential
source of conflict here.
Both people would rather be at an
equilibrium than to be mal coordinated,
uncoordinated,
but play a one wants to go to Bourne
ultimatum and play a two wants to go to
good shepherd. And actually I thought
Nina's strategy there was pretty good.
Nina's version of communication was,
I'm going to Bourne ultimatum, right?
Right. That that basically
fix things. Right?
But you could imagine that a
communication could break down here.
There could be a negotiation going on.
All right. So think about, uh, I mean,
I don't think,
I don't want to push this too hard,
but think about other games where people
are communicating to feel an or to
avoid a feeder of,
of coordination.
There's a strike negotiation
going on as we speak. Events.
It's a critical moment this morning,
uh,
up in Detroit between General
Motors and the United auto workers.
And I didn't want to say that strikes only
about ms coordination, but clearly, uh,
everyone's better off if they come to
some agreement. Uh, rather than strike,
there's at least some agreement is
going to be better for everybody than a
strike.
And yet,
because they personally were conflicting
interests that basically in that case,
conflicting interest about
health and pension payments.
It could well be that you
end up failing to court.
All right.
All right,
so this game has a name and
actually somebody mentioned
it last time and one who
is the person who mentioned this last
time, somebody, somebody mentioned this.
What, what, what was the,
what is this game called?
W shattered out battle of the sexes.
That's good to this game is
called the battle of the sexes.
Yeah,
I will. We'll see it in various forms
over the course of the semester.
It's actually very interesting game games
like it, they are coordination games,
but different people disagree about
where you'd like to coordinate.
All right,
so,
so much for talking about coordination
games and helping you real dating
strategy, um, this being
a game theory class,
there's at least one game we have to
discuss. Uh, and we, we'll come to it now.
So we're going to spend most of the
rest of today, uh, talking about, uh,
[inaudible]. And before I
do that, let me just check.
How many of you have seen Cornell
duopoly before? Raise your hand.
The sentence just for me year.
I said maybe at half of you,
so those of you who have, don't worry.
I mean, this will be a bit review,
but we'll see it more through the
eyes of game theory this time.
And for those of you haven't, don't worry,
we're going to go through it. Okay. Okay.
So this is a classic game habits, one
of the most famous games. And therefore,
uh,
we're studying in the class.
That was a purely game theory exercise.
One reason for studying Kono do you openly
is that so far we've discussed how to
find Nash equilibrium when there are a few
players,
each of whom has few strategies and we've
discussed how to find Nash equilibrium
where there are many players,
each of whom has few strategies.
And this is a game where there
are few players and be too,
but they have many strategies.
All right?
They actually have a continuum of
strategies. All right? All right.
For those people who aren't familiar
with this and are worried about the
economics of it in particular,
it's gone over in considerable detail in
chapter six of the textbook in chapter
six of the textbook.
All right,
so just motivate this a little bit.
So there's two reasons why this game is
interesting. So I say what would it is?
So this is a game in which there are
two firms who are competing in the same
market and we'll give a bit
more detail in a second.
And one reason this game is interesting
from the point of you of economics is
this game lies between the two extreme
cases that you learn about in your
interaction.
Omics pass,
one extreme case is perfect competition
or the other extreme case is monopoly.
So this isn't,
this is really the first attempt way back
in the late century to study a market
that somewhere in the middle of what had
happened, most markets are all right,
there are two firms and we're
interested in two things here.
We're interested in what's going
to happen in these markets.
And then from a welfare point of view,
from a policy point of view,
we're interested about whether this
is good for consumers or good for uh,
producers or what, right? How,
how this relates to profits and
consumer surplus. All right?
So with that in mind,
let's just set the game up.
So the players in this
game are two phones,
two firms, and the strategies
in this game for the firms,
and this is going to
turn out to be important.
The strategies are the quantities that
they produce of an identical products.
All right?
So they have the quantities
they produce.
So each of them producers,
okay.
Oh, of an identical product. So front,
as far as the consumers are concerned,
these two products are
perfect substitutes.
You could think of these as two
companies producing bottled water.
And now I'm going to get
hundreds of letters saying
novel bottled waters are the
same, especially from it,
uh, Italians and the French.
But nevermind does a switch to
pretend that they are. All right.
So just to emphasize that the strategies
are quantities rather than using s,
let me use Q today to be the
strategist. So, so Qai and,
and uh,
a Q minus sigh oh Q one and
Q two will be the strategies.
All right?
Now I need to give a little bit more
structure on the payoff when I get to the
pay offs. So in particular, I need to
tell you what is the cost of production
and the cost of production in this game
is simply going to be c times cute.
All right? So if I produce
one unit, it costs me.
See if I produced two units,
it costs me to see if I
produce a hundred units,
it costs me a hundred c
and high produce, uh, 0.7,
three five units like cost me 0.7,
three, five, six. Awesome. All right,
so for those people who took intro
economics, which is most of you,
this is a game.
This is a,
a setting in which we have
constant marginal costs,
constant marginal cost, the constant
marginal costs. It's, see, all right,
and I'll need to tell you about how
prices are determined in this market.
So prices are determined as follows.
Uh,
prices depend on some parameters.
I'm just going to call a and B.
Uh,
I looked it up.
Let me write the equation and
then we'll see what it looks like.
So basically the idea is that
the more these firms produce,
so the more of the total
quantity produced Q1 plus Q two,
the lower is the price in the marketplace
for this product. All right. I,
let's just draw a picture of the hat.
We'll come back to this in a minute.
Let's draw a picture which
we can keep for later.
Actually that's saved myself
some time and written this down.
All right,
so this, this, uh, Mr
Equation I've just written,
you can imagine Q1 plus Q2 total quantity
on the horizontal access and you can
imagine price on the vertical access.
And basically what we're saying is that
prices depend on total quantities as
follows,
where the slope of this line
smoke with this line is minus B.
All right? Now for those of you who
took economics one 15 or coolant,
what is the name of this lion?
I've just drawn because that was,
that was way fewer responses and they
wanted, all right, let's try again.
What's the name of this downward sloping
hint, hint line that I've just drawn?
It's a demand Kat. Thank
you. So demand curve.
All right.
This is the demand it tells me,
but they'll be around and look at the,
look at how prices
correspond to quantities.
It tells me the quantity
demanded at any given price.
All right, we'll come back to
that in a second. But meanwhile,
let's just finish up what we're
doing here and put in payoffs.
So payoffs for these firms
are going to depend on,
uh, on profits or pay off the farms. Aim
to maximize
profit
and profit is going to be given by
p times Q minus.
Sorry, it's just to throw this dude.
Let's do this for from one. Alright,
let's be careful.
Let's do this.
The Fun one I'll do if I want
us to come to in a second.
So the payoff for from one as it depends
on the quantity that she produces and
the quantity that the other firm
produces is going to be prices times the
quantity that foam one
producers minus costs
times the quantity that she
produces. All right? All right,
so this is,
this term here is revenues.
It's Tom.
Here
it's revenues. And this term
here is total costs, right?
Revenues minus costs makes profits.
And again,
those people who are less
familiar with economics,
I'm hoping this is not gonna be too hard,
but you read up on the, okay. All right.
I want to going to do here is I'm
going to substitute in for prices.
All right? So I've got this
expression for prices here.
Here it is.
And I want to plug it into that p that.
Okay. All right, so let's, I'm going
to want to rewrite it now with that,
with that p expanded hours.
All right, so I'm going to get,
and I'm going to multiply out at the
same time. So I'm going to have a Q one
minus B squared.
Okay.
Minus B Q one Q two
minus c Q one. All right,
so all I'm doing here,
nothing,
nothing particularly exciting.
I'm simply plugging this expression then
for p and then I multiplied the whole
thing out cause I,
cause it was all multiplied by Q
one and I should warn you again,
I'm very likely to make mistakes
when doing this kind of thing.
So please catch me if I do.
All right?
So here I have a new expression for from
ones profit and I could do the same for
from too, but I'm not going
to because it's, that would
get boring. Okay. All right.
So this is, this is just
from one spot. Okay.
Now with this in hand,
what I want to do is,
I mean for him to have
a similar expression.
What I want to do is I want to figure
out the Nash equilibrium of this,
of this game.
I know I won't get down on the board.
I want to figure out the Nash equilibrium
off this game.
Both firms are producing quantities.
Both firms are trying to maximize profit.
And I want to find out the
Nash Equilibrium. How do
I go about that exercise?
What's the what? What do I need to do
to find each firm's Nash Equilibrium?
How do we always find Nash
equilibrium when we're not guessing?
What are we doing?
Anybody?
So when you were over there, who's gonna
be way off camera, but we can perhaps,
I'm going to make him mad
quick. I'm, I'm sorry.
I see he's way in the corner that
come, come, come this way a little bit.
It's a bit closer to the aisle.
There you go.
Well, we would just delete the, uh, we
would eternal iterative lead, delete,
dominated.
Could do that. We could do that.
We could try it for the domain.
His strategies and see if I can see that
process converged high and something
else in mind here. Something that's more
of more straight forward. What else?
What else does that,
so the guy in red,
mmm.
Identify the best responses of each player
as a function of the others and find
out where they intersect.
I guess that more that was correct.
I sent more loudly shouting,
um,
identify the best responses of each player
as a function of the others and find
out where they intersect. Okay, good.
So what we're gonna do is we're going to
figure out play or one's best response
quantity to each possible
choice to flare to.
And then we're going to flip it around
and figuring out player twos best
response quantity to each
possible choice of player one.
And then we're going to see
where they were. They were,
those were those coincide
where they cross. All right?
So just like we've done several
times from four, all right.
It's only ordained to do then is I need
to figure out what his player ones best
response for each possible choice.
Q2 of player too.
All right. So how do I do
that? How do I do that?
I wanted to find the best response.
How do I do that?
Everyone's looking like this
is a bit your Mo. Really?
Anybody, anybody to
cold call somebody? No?
Yeah, I the thought of that. Yeah. Yeah,
yeah. Uh, sorry. Athletic Day for you.
Somebody that way at the back there.
Sorry
that up.
And shout.
Find the best response function by
differentiating this and maximizing the
function for every Q two. Okay, good.
Good, good. So what we're going to do is,
all right, good. We're
good. We're going to,
we're trying to maximize the best
response is going to maximize these, uh,
these prophets. All
right, so in particular,
what we're going to do to find out what,
what quantity Q1 maximizes this
profits for each choice of, of Q2.
We're going to differentiate this
with respect to Q one and then what?
And then still equal to zero. Okay. So
again, let me just take a look out there.
How many of you remember this?
We did this once before I did this bus.
How many of you remember
this from, from your, uh,
high school calculus days
or from one 12th? Quite a.
Quite a number of you actually
were on it, right? Okay, good.
So we're gonna do is we're going to
differentiate this thing to find a first
order condition.
We're going to differentiate,
okay.
With respect to Q1, right? The thing
we're trying, the, our control variable,
they were trying to maximize the thing
with those back to and set it equal to
zero. All right, so what I'm going
to get, so this, this term here,
a Q one is going to become an ae and
this term here minus B Q squared is going
to become a
to B Q one and this term here minus B
Q one Q two is gonna become a minus B Q
two and the last term minus CQ
one is going to become a minus c.
All right? And we're happy with that. I
don't want to, there was a differentiated,
this fairly simple function
with respect to key one.
And since I want to find them a maximum,
but I'm going to do is I'm going to
set this equal to zero. All right?
At my maximum up to Hato retro
indicate this is the Arg Max, uh,
at my maximum, I'm going to set this
thing you will deserve now, but it's just,
it is in some sense we're being nerdy
in this class despite our attempts to go
dating, we're being nerdy. Lex
Actually, uh, be a little bit careful.
This was a first order condition or first
on a necessary condition actually need
to check the second order condition.
So how do I check the
second order condition?
Yeah,
I differentiate again, right?
I differentiate a second
time and check the sign.
The second oral condition,
I differentiate this expression
again with respect to Q one,
the early phase Kuwan appears here is
here. So when I differentiate again,
I must going to get minus two B
and sure enough that's negative,
which is what I wanted to know.
That's just to check that
what I'm finding this thing,
I'm finding a maximum and not a
minimum. All right, good. Good. Okay.
So this is our key expression
and I'm going to use this expression,
I'm going to solve it for Q one.
So the best response for player one as a
function of what player to chooses Kutu
is just equal to the Q one Hatton,
this expression.
And if I solve that out carefully, I will
no doubt make a mistake when it's dry.
It, uh, I'm going to have a minus c over
to be
minus
Q two over two.
All right? So try that at home. But I
think I did that right? So I took the,
I took this to the other side and I
have divided through by two B and the B
here, counsel. All right, I want
to just start that a second.
Make sure I don't right. And very, very
capable of getting this things wrong.
All right,
good.
So what I have here is an equation that
tells me player one's best response for
each possible choice of player too.
All right?
And I could do the same
thing for player to,
to find player two's best response for
every possible choice of player one or
the other hand. We know it, you know
the math is going to be the same.
So let's cheese.
Okay.
I know that play a his best response
for every possible choice of player one,
which if we'd done it would be Q two hat
is going to equal a minus c over to B
minus Q. Want over to right? So I'm just,
I'm just flipping around
the twos and the ones.
So at this point I found player one's
best response as a function of Q two I
found player two's best response as a
function of Q one and the way I did it,
just remember the way he did it was I
applied a little bit of one 12 and our
high school calculus, right?
Essentially single variable.
All right. Now before we could just
solve at this point, but it's not,
let's draw this. Let's draw this. Okay.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna go back to my picture
and draw these functions.
I'll just remind us what is function.
It's a minus c over to B minus Q two over
two as equivalently for a plan to all
right. That's it. That's the thing,
I it just hidden by the board.
Now what I want to do is I want to draw
a picture I little bit like we did for
the partnership game.
Turn the partnership game.
We put efforts on these axes and now I'm
going to put quantities on these axes.
So this is going to be the choice of
player one and this is going to be
the choice of player too. And what I
want to do is I want to figure out what,
what this looks like, what, uh,
for each Q two that you give
me or that player to chooses.
I want to find out and draw what
is player ones. Best response.
All right, everyone happy what I'm doing
here? All right, so let's start somewhere.
And what we're gonna do is we'll
refer back to this other picture,
which is why I left it here.
All right, so in particular,
what would be player ones?
Best response if a two.
It didn't produce it all.
How we find that without worrying
about the economics of it? A second.
How will we find that?
This is a math exercise.
Just oppose play a two doesn't produce it.
All
right. What is player one's best
response? Someone read it off of me.
Wait when we cold call
somebody out or you can,
yeah.
Hey mine minus c over to B.
All right,
so so shout that out over two weeks.
If I plug it,
plug it Q two equals zero and
to hear this term disappears,
right and I just get a minus c over
to be so of that's what's that?
What's that telling me?
I mean put the 45 degree line in here.
What's that telling me? It's as if
play a two chooses not to produce,
then play a one's best
response is a minus c
over to be.
Now I claim it that conscious,
a minus c over to be
actually has another name.
What's the name of that quantity?
What's the name of the quantity?
A minus C of a to be. Once we,
once we escape the Algebra,
just think about it in terms of economics.
What does thinking about it the best?
Let's go back to the previous picture.
If player two is producing nothing,
player two is producing nothing. Then
what is player one? Oneness. Effectively,
he's a monopolist or she's a monopolist.
All right,
so we know how to figure out monopoly
quantities from what we did in one 15 or
equivalent courses. Let me just finish
the picture here. Here's my demand curve.
Here's my constant Marshall cost
at, see. All right. I want to,
I want to use this picture on the left
now to figure out what the monopoly
quantity is. Can anyone tell me out?
It's cold. Call Tom Buddy again. Ah,
well raise your hand if you took
one 1501 10 oh one 50 oh no, no,
no, no. I know more. He took it than that.
It's so it's, it's a Prereq for the class,
right? Raise your hands if you didn't
take any of those things. Right.
All right, so keep your hands up a
cocoa. Do you haven't got the hand up?
Yeah.
Anybody, anybody? Go ahead
passing the buck yet. Do you door
to tell me what the, where's the,
where's the monopoly quantity
on this picture? No, try
it. Try to work with that.
The one with the woman and woman one
in there. Yeah. That's where you are.
There's a woman here. Yeah. Oh really?
Don't remember. I don't remember.
I don't remember who else.
Who else doesn't remember?
What was it?
Somebody I don't remember is a good reply.
Or if you're,
if you're auditioning for it
to be the attorney general,
but it's not such a good offer.
Anybody,
somebody hit somebody
help me out. Hey, where's,
where's the monopoly quantity on this
picture? It's good review exercise.
Yeah. It's where the marginal revenue
is equal to the marginal cost. Oh,
it's where marginal revenue
equals Marshall because I
should have picked him out
of there. So when people, by the way,
it's where marginal revenue
equals marginal costs. Right.
The reason I speak on the SOM people,
if they their,
their ambition in life is to Ronald
Monopoly, right? Say, alright,
couple days I haven't drawn the marginal
revenue curve yet. Right? Right.
You can't actually see
the marginal revenue here.
What is the marginal revenue look like?
And this pitch,
I don't even go to the same guy.
The guy in in Brown. Where's,
where's the marginal revenue look like?
What's the most,
whenever you look back on
this picture on the left,
it's one half the slope of
the price. Yeah. Oh, it's, I
guess it's twice the slope,
but that's fine. And I know
what you mean. All right.
So the marginal revenue here
that's been in a different color,
the marginal revenue
look,
something like this.
Alright.
And as,
I don't know what your name is as the
guy who said the monopoly quantity,
monopoly quantity,
it's when marginal revenue
equals marginal costs. All right.
And as we know,
this line here has twice the slope of the
original line of the [inaudible] cove.
So the slope of this thing is minus two
B.
I know I'm going to claim that this
monopoly corner, the I claimed before,
it's like our intuition says if
the other firm isn't producing,
my best response must be
produced by monopoly quantity,
which I can see on this shut.
And I also planned,
but the math is telling me just to kind
of nerdy math is telling me that that
quantity is a minus c over to B and
I claim that they're the same thing.
How can I see that? The same thing. Well,
look here I have a line of slope minus
two how far down does it have to go?
It has to go a minus c down as pink line
has to drop off from a all the way to
see how far along do I have to go to drop
off a minus c when I have slope minus
to be honest,
a minus seat over to be right.
That's not even calculus something he
really all at the high school. Okay.
All right. Okay, so this
monopoly quantity is indeed.
Hey, minus c over TV. All right,
I'm going to ask again if some of
this being coming out of the fog,
I mean you mental sent
with the Algebra before,
but some of this sort of pictures have
you seen before as good review exercise
for some of you who have taken one 50
and are about to take one 50 or that now.
All right,
so we found precisely 1.0
this best response picture
and there's a lot of points
to find and it's 20 past 12 so
we're gonna get going. All right,
so let's try and find another point.
All right, so it's a different question.
How much quantity would from to have
to produce in order to induce from one,
not to produce it all.
That again,
how much quantity would from two half
to produce in order to induce from one's
best response to be zero.
All right. There's that. That helped
me out. [inaudible] it's Katy, right?
Is that right? The woman in green
and it's going to make to Katie. Oh,
there's Mike posted buyers. No
of mine. Sorry. Yeah, yeah. Hey,
mine is c over to B. All right, so, so
that's just solving out the Algebras.
We're saying, we're saying what, what?
Q solves 80 minus c over to B
minus Q two over two equals zero,
right? What Q to Purdue
makes the sink? Well,
does zero and Katie's answer
is solving out the Algebra.
Here is the Q two.
The soul is,
this must be a minus c, uh, over over B.
All right,
that's right.
Why can I see that one on the picture
though? Let's go back to the economics.
All right, so I'm claiming
that the song quantity up here,
I claim this quantity is a minus c Overbey
such that if from two producers that
much quantity from one
we'll just produce nothing,
right?
But that's just kind of Algebra and math.
What can I say it on this picture?
What quarter?
See if produced by from two would cost
from one to shut down on this picture.
Yeah, it's going to Mike
and in here, sorry, again,
that's where the marginal cost and the
demand thing demand lines intersect.
All right, so, uh, it's
here, right? It's here.
It's where it's where marginal.
It's where the marginal cost
and the demand curve intersects
and watch Dan tuition.
Well, let's work it out,
I suppose from two has produced
all of this quantity up to here.
All right? So from two is already
producing all of this quantity.
So already just from,
from two's production,
the price has been driven
all the way down to costs.
All right? So if I, I'm from one,
if I produce any more quantity,
what's going to happen
to the price fibers?
Any quantity at all in addition
to what's out there already.
What's going to happen to the price?
It's going to be pushed below. Cost.
All right, so I'll be producing
this stuff is water at cost.
See and only getting P, which is isn't
going to be less than. So you in return,
Toby losing money on any product,
any product that I produce,
I want to see that and I'll say it again.
So from to from to produce
is all the way up to here.
Yeah.
That any product produced by from one
is going to push prices even lower in
particular.
There'll be lower here than costs and
so you'll make losses on that product.
All right.
What's the name of going back to
economics one 15 what's the name for this?
Quantity. The quantity where
demand and Marshall costs equal.
That's the, that's the
competitive quantity. All right,
so this is the perfect
competition quantity in a
perfectly competitive market.
That's exactly where
prices are going to end up.
This is not a perfectly
competitive market, but if it were,
that's where price is going to end up.
All right?
So we have the monopoly quantity here
and we have the competitive quantity here
and in between. What does this
best response curve look like?
Somebody, it's a straight line. It's
a straight line. Thank you. All right,
so in between,
this is just a spray line.
All right,
so here is the best response of from
one to each possible choice of I'm too.
All right. Everyone's looking
really like this was hard,
but it can't be that hard. You see in
most of you seen this before. All right,
so don't, if you haven't
seen before, don't panic.
All I did was I did a
little bit of calculus.
It's a bit of Algebra and
then I drew the thing.
I just drew the thing.
Okay,
so this is from one's best response as
a function of Q two what is from two's
best response as a function
of Q one let's just get that.
Just to remind you, the way we read this
is you give me a quantity of from too,
I find from one's best response by going
across to the pink client and dropping
down,
so a from to produces this amount.
Then one's best response is
this amount if from Jupiter is,
is this amount than foam ones?
Best response. Is this. Alright.
Now conversely,
how do we find from two's best response
as a function of Q one what does that
look like? Yeah, to take it to get the,
I guess two guys in front of you,
shout it out.
It's a symmetrical across the
45 degree. All right. Right.
It's reflected across the 45 degree line.
So let's reflect these two points.
That's will be here.
This will be what would be a bit
more careful, but miss by a mile.
Let me just try again.
I missed by a mile, which is, which
is a problem in drawing my lines,
but never mind.
Yeah.
All right,
so this will be the monopoly
quantity for from to,
and this is the competitor quantity.
All right,
so if I draw on that better,
it would look as if this was
half of this distance, right?
I didn't draw it. Well, try and
draw it better in your notes.
All right. All right? So this is
a minus c over B and this
is anyway a c of a to B.
So this distance and this
distance and had to be the same.
And the way I've drawn it
this donut at the same at all.
All right?
Okay.
And the way we read this green graph is
you give me a choice of from one he won.
I go up to the Green Line and go across,
and this tells me the best response
for fun too.
All right?
So at this point, how many of you
have seen this picture before? Good.
Many of you have seen it
before. All right? So, uh,
I think we can really cold call somebody
for this one. All right? So, uh, uh,
somebody tell me and
pick some time to cope,
but when you cold call somebody alia,
anybody can close by.
Okay? Okay. Okay. So
here's the tough question.
Watch the Nash Equilibrium on this
picture where the green and the pink line
intersect. All right, where are the
green and the pink line intersect? Right?
All right, so this must be, this
must be the Nash Equilibrium, right?
That wasn't hard. Right. Okay. Okay.
All right. Now. Okay, so why, what was,
go back again.
Why is this the Nash Equilibrium?
Because at this point as
in the partnership game,
was there a similar thing
as on the partnership game
where the best response is
Intersex is where player Wong is playing
a best response to play a two and play
a two is playing a
restaurant supplier one.
So this is the Nash Equilibrium
in this corner of game, right?
Let's do a little bit of,
just to make sure we can find this thing.
All right,
so we're going to do is
set these two things
are equal to each other.
Okay.
Put in stores here.
Yeah,
so at at the national equilibrium
quantities shouldn't really do this,
but never mind at the Nash Equilibrium.
Quantity's I'm going to have Q one star
is equal to a minus CEO to be Q two
stars that Dra and Q two
star is equal to amen.
A C of a to B you one star two.
All right,
and I'm going to solve this out by sending
[inaudible] since I know the game is
symmetric
and they weren't on the 45 degree line.
All right,
so all I have to do here to do this
algebraically is to solve out these
equations.
So let's try and do that.
So putting Q1 in here,
right?
If I substitute Q one in here,
what would it give me?
It'll give me Q one star is equal
to a minus c over to B minus Q one.
Start over to,
let's multiply both sides by two.
I'll get to Q one star is
equal to a minus c over B
minus Q one star.
Take that to the other side.
They have three Q one star is equal to
a minus c over B and finally divide by
three Q one star is equal to a minus C
I have a by three B.
All right,
so that crossing point actually occurs
at a minus c over three B and they're
going to look desperately. My ta
is, it didn't make her to did.
I didn't screw that up, I think. I think,
I think I didn't screw that up. All right,
so this is sometimes called the corn Oh,
quantity.
This game,
this game of imperfect competition between
two firms competing in court disease
was thought up and,
and and uh,
studied by a French economist
called core know, uh,
almost a hundred years before nash.
And I said a hundred is really before
the invention of Game Theory, right?
Someone had figured out
this arm stuff for this guy.
All right.
Okay. So what do we know so
far? I'll leave the Algebra.
They're transferred up here.
You stuck.
He one star equals Q two
star equals a minus c
over three B.
All right.
So so far we've hit, we've been
working pretty hard and we haven't,
I guess moon's a lot.
We just kind of solve the thing out.
Now we get to draw some lessons
on this thing. All right?
So everybody who's feeding a little bit
shell shocked from having been doing
Algebra and calculus and drawing pictures
and feeling like they've been cheated
into taking a class that looks far
too much like economics. Calm down.
We're going to actually talk about it now.
Okay.
All right.
So one thing to remark about this gay,
why don't we learned immediately is that
this game is different in a significant
way to different from the
partnership game. I mean,
obviously it's different because
it's about to make a difference,
but I mean in terms of the
game theory is different.
It's different from the partnership game.
It's different from the investment game.
What is it that's different
about this came from the Po?
What's the obvious thing I was looking
at this picture that makes it different
from the partnership? Yeah.
In the partnership game,
the best response lines sloped up.
Is that right?
The more I did have my strategy,
the more the other player did is a
best response in the investment game.
The more likely I was to invest,
the more likely you are,
the more you want to do invest.
Right? But in this game,
we have the exact opposites.
The more player one produces,
the more player one produces the less
player to wants to produce and the more
player to producers,
the less player one wants to produce.
All right, so this game is a
game, not a strategic compliments,
but a strategic substitutes.
I don't want to be careful here.
It's not,
it's not that these goods are substitutes.
I mean clear. That's also the case,
right? If both your firms are producing
bottled water and it's identical,
right, then, then the goods
themselves are substitutes.
That's not the point I'm making here.
Strategic substitutes as a strategy is,
is a statement about
the nature of the game.
So strategic substitutes is telling
me that my strategy is the strategic
substitute of your strategy.
If the more I do have my strategy,
the less you want to do of yours,
and conversely,
the more you want to do of your strategy,
the less I want to do.
Right?
Okay.
Well, let's come back to the
question we started with,
which has to do with profits
and so on and society.
We know that if these players
play these games, if we,
at least if we believe
in Nash equilibrium it,
then they're going to produce these
quantities they're going to produce here.
Right?
Well,
let's ask a different question.
He usually these firms is trying
to maximize profit. All right,
but how about the total profit in the
industry? Whereas each of these firms,
we know where the, that playing a bass
response is maximizing their profits.
Taking this,
given what the other firms doing,
but how about total industry profits?
Are they being maximized here?
Who thinks total industry
profits are being maximized?
Who thinks total energy profits and not
being maximized? All right, good. Good.
So not to shout out. Okay, so total
ownership of it to not being maximized.
Where on the picture? I don't know.
Getting on a bit of cold calling in here.
Where on the picture maximize
this total industry profits.
Hmm. We're on the pitch of
maximizes total industry profits.
We had, we had it before. That's what
else? Yeah, no, no idea. No idea.
People taking the fifth. Yeah.
Yeah. The guy in there. Yeah.
Is it at the monopoly,
right? Monopoly. Exactly.
So clearly if we punish
the monopoly quantity,
by definition the monopoly quantity
maximizes total industry profits.
And for example,
if from to shut down and from one
produced it's monopoly profits,
it's monopoly quantity that would
maximize profits. And conversely,
if from one shot down and from to
produced it's monopoly quantity,
that would maximize industry profits.
All right,
where else in ms pet shop
maximize energy profits.
So this point maximized industry
industry profits and this point maximizes
industry profits.
Where else maximizes industry profits?
Anybody?
Well,
how about all the points in between here
from one produced nothing and from to
produce the monopoly quantity and
hear from to produced nothing.
And from one produced
the monopoly quantity.
But you could also just split the
monopoly quantity for example,
half half at this point here.
All right,
so the first,
what did to make more money?
One thing they could do is they
could sign an agreement saying,
why don't each of us
produced not our core,
no quantity but produce half
monopoly profits. Sorry,
half monopoly,
half a monopoly quantity.
And that would produce this much.
All right?
It's a foam one would be producing half
its monopoly property quantity in fem.
Two would be Buddhism, Hellfest
monopoly quantity. All right.
So what's wrong with that agreement? So
he had to have that, whether they there,
uh, to water companies are that
Poland Spring and uh, and uh, um,
cocacola I guess these days of signing
this agreement saying that each one's
going to produce Hoffman off like one
did eat and what's gonna go wrong with
that agreement?
Yeah,
the got the guy in red.
First of all, it's illegal. It's
illegal. It's illegal, right? So,
so even without the being
an attorney general,
somebody might be awakened the Justice
Department and know and notice that
actually illegal. All right? It's
illegal to sign an agreement, uh, to, uh,
to sign a contract saying you're going
to restrict a quantities. It's illegal.
So they can't sign that as a contract,
but hey are they could just
agree in the doers, right?
So Coca Cola in Poland spring,
it could just agree to produce half
the quantity of water each day.
All right,
what's going to go, what, what might
go wrong in that agreement? It's just,
let's just suppose that that game is
just being played once for now. Hi.
And suppose that this is Coca Cola is
quantity and this is Poland springs
quantity. And suppose your, the, your,
the manager of Poland Spring, right?
So water is coming out of the ground
in Maine for you. All right. And you,
you know that it's Coca Cola guy is
going to produce this quantity here.
Alright, so this is Q m those are
two. Do you ever receive? All right,
so let's,
let's pick on our two managers.
It's have to people who've spoken before.
So the guy in the red shirts name is
Steve and I guess in red he should be the
coca coca cola gay. Right. All
right. And uh, let's pick on our,
our Jimmy Stewart from last week, whose
name is Patrick, right? Uh, and again,
can I get a mic? Come on,
Patrick. All right. All right.
So Steve and Patrick of
the art respectively,
the managers of Coca Cola and uh,
and Poland spring.
And uh, here it is, right, right.
And Patrick Patrick believes that the
coca cola manager he's going to is just
make this coke and Pepsi's, it's two
identical that near enough of identical,
right? So there's a coke and
Pepsi went that, that will
confuse me last. All right,
so Patrick,
our manager of Pepsi believes that Coca
Cola is going to produce this quantity
and he's agreed to produce this quantity.
What is Patrick actually going to do?
Patrick, are you going to do? Huh?
So I should cheat and,
and picnic on me on my best response line.
It's much farther out so I'll, I'll
produce it more than that. Quantity.
All right, so Patrick, just being Jimmy's
do it or not? Actually, when he's in the,
in the, when he's playing, the manager of
Pepsi is going to produce more of this,
uh,
undrinkable liquid and produce
this quantity here. All
right, so what is this?
This is Patrick's best response
to the other guy producing
the monopoly quantity.
Alright.
All right.
So Patrick's response and Pepsi is to
overproduce rolls up to the monopoly
quantity. Actually overproduce even
roads into the corner quantity, right?
And produce all the way out of here.
Okay,
so Patrick's producing here,
but what about Mister Coca Cola guy?
All right. Now, Mr Coca Cola
Guy knows Patrick pretty well,
but you know there've be in the same
industry for a while. I missed uh, uh,
Mr. Koch, Hilda, his
name is Stephen. Stephen.
Stephen Presumably knows that Patrick
is actually going to produce this
quantity. Sorry, this quantity.
Okay.
So Steven, what do you, what, what,
what, what should you produce?
Increased my own production to,
to match my of my best response line.
Good.
So anticipating
that Patrick is going to
think that Steven's a sock
habit and to Patrick's going
to cheat on him and produce too much.
Steven's going to produce the best
response to that and he's going to produce
this quantity here.
So what is this?
This is player twos best response.
So player ones,
best response to play it to
producing half monopoly out but
alright.
But Patrick knows Steven pretty well.
He knows those guys who run in Coca
Cola are pretty snow mark guys.
So Patrick knows that the guy who runs
coca cola is going to anticipate that the
guy who runs Pepsi is going to
cheat on the guy who runs coca cola.
And hence the guy Runscope of color
is going to be our best response to
Patrick's cheese in quantity.
So what quantity is, uh,
is Patrick and a produce
auction then out on a pretty close to
the Cornell, you delivery. All right,
so you're going to go to here to this
point here is don't even write this.
This is the best response of planning
one to the best responsive player to,
to the best response of player
one to play or to producing
half monopoly output and the lots
of brackets. Yeah. All right. Hey,
can anyone see where this process is going
through? This process is going right?
It's going back. It's going back
to the Nash Equilibrium, right?
Each of them is trying
to buy a best response.
What we anticipate the other person's
going to do, and in this game,
if they keep on doing that,
it's going to drag them back to
Nash equilibrium to be careful here.
This will be true of all games,
but in this game playing
best response to each other,
figuring out that in fact the other guy
is going to going to cheat on me or the
other guys or anticipate that I'm going
to cheat on him with other guys and I
anticipate that I'm going to anticipate
that he's going to cheat on me,
et Cetera, et cetera. We'll eventually
drag us back to the court. Oh, quantity.
All right,
so it's going to be pretty difficult
for us to sustain this joint monopoly
output. There's collusive agreement.
We can't let the courts enforce it.
What Coca Cola and Pepsi is, we really
don't want to bring the math yet again,
although maybe we do, I
don't know. All right?
So basically we're stuck with this
verbal agreement and we both have an
incentive to cheat and produce
more whatever it is, sugar water.
Right?
Okay.
No,
in practice,
this is not the only problem facing two
firms who are producers who are trying
to produce the monopoly output,
right?
In practice when firms trying
to have these, uh, agreements,
which are not contracts to try
and produce joint monopoly output.
What else goes wrong?
So here you could imagine some
firms trying to have an agreement.
We know they can't sign the
legal agreements, but let's,
let's take that off the table. So for
example, in around 1900 and America,
or a little bit earlier, let's say,
let's say a eight and 18 in America,
it really isn't clear that it was
illegal to write agreements to say,
we'll restrict what it is.
Right?
Firms didn't use to write that kind of
agreement, but still something went wrong.
What went wrong?
So we're getting a little bit further
away from the game and more back into the
real world. Yeah. What kinds
of things went wrong? I want
to get some news nearer.
Mike, can I, can I, can I get the
woman here they are the Yale shut
without a contract.
Yeah.
There's no means of enforcement. All
right. So, so it might be, again,
there's a problem with enforcement,
although actually in each
and each year in America,
it's not clear that they couldn't have
enforced that contract. All right,
so one problem is unenforceable se,
right. But no new far I'll go with that.
Might have been a problem. What
else? The guy next, next time.
Yeah.
If they're not at the competitive outcome,
they could undercut price
and take the entire market.
Let's be careful.
I will come back that next time,
but right now we're competing in
quantities, right? So, so we're not,
we're not fixing prices here
and even leaving prices,
we're just producing coca cola and
Pepsi and for want of a better word,
spewing it out into the market. All
right. What? What else goes wrong here?
Well, one thing that goes wrong
is it supposed coke and Pepsi?
Why able to either to write a contract
or whatever just to stay in giant
monopoly outputs at this high price
is price, which is, oh, I'm sorry.
I just called con presumed positive
profits and the industry and he's going to
turn out. Therefore, the price
is going to be above costs.
These firms making a lot of profits.
What is going to happen in this industry?
It's interesting.
It's got a lot of profit or a around that.
What's gonna Happen in this industry?
Yeah, the the guy in the blue shirt here.
I like this guy here.
I know
editor could join the market.
All right.
Another foam is going to come
in and produce similar products.
So Dr Pepper or something that
the same is that the third one?
Someone else is going to come in and
Produce Cola and this industry and that's
exactly, that's exactly what happened in
the u s at the turn of the last century
companies did Bruce agreements
to restrict, for example,
the production of paper and the production
of rubber and the production of steel
and the production of iron and the
production of, of uh, of a railway lines.
Actually he didn't quite
complicated things and sure enough,
what you see very quickly emerging is
new entrants entering the market to say,
hey, these firms restricting
that their quantities,
we can get in there and make money.
All right,
so new and a competitive fringe of firms
is going to enter and drive prices down.
Now,
I talked about that in 1900 America.
Where is that happened in the
20th century? More dramatically.
So we know the early example in
sort of sort of Golden Age America,
but what else did we see a competitor
fringe enter when there was a collusive
agreement to keep prices,
keep quantities down
airlines
to airlines. Okay, good. The airlines
as an example, we've seen that. What,
where else?
Oh,
y'all is probably the classic example
of airlines is a good example. Okay,
so an oil,
we all know that in the s and the late
sixties early seventies OPEC was formed
precisely to restrict quantity among
the major oil producing countries.
And very quickly we see, take it,
other countries take advantage of this,
just start producing oil profitably.
So who,
who are the competitive
French against OPEC
anyway?
Well, the bread swa for
a start, the Brits, uh,
England and Scotland, I
should say Britain. Anyway,
started producing oil in the North Sea.
Lots of countries in Latin America
started looking and finding oil.
And of course, Russian oil,
uh, uh, started being a very,
very profitable. All right,
so there's two,
there are various reasons why it's hard
to maintain this collusive agreement.
One is there's an incentive to cheat and
another is that other firms are going
to enter.
But before we leave this,
let's just pose the question we
started with suppose. In fact,
we do end up back at
the corn. Oh, quantity.
So here we are back at the
corner quantity, right?
How does this quantity compare and how
does that for the prices compare and how
to profits compare with monopoly prices
on the one hand and competitive prices
on the other? All right, so we
know, we know the courts did.
It's going to be produced. We
figured that out. Here it is.
We know that the contract is
going to be produced. Each firm,
each firm is going to produce a minus
c over three B and there are two such
firms. So the total quantity
produced in the market,
total quantity
will be to a minus c over three B.
All right.
How does that compare to
the monopoly quantity? Well,
the monopoly quantity
was a minus c over to be,
the competitive quantity was a minus c
over B to remind you of those that are on
a picture.
Here's a minus t a Tubie
and here's a MSC over B.
So this is the total quantity produced
on this equilibrium in this corner,
Nash Equilibrium. How does it
compare to the monopoly quantity?
Enter the competitive quantity.
Anybody
a little bit of just staring at the
board, which, which of these is bigger?
So I claim that this total quantity being
produced is less than the competitive
quantity,
but more in total than
the monopoly quantity.
All right.
I was about to hit it the wrong way round.
That's right.
So the total quantity being produced
is less than will be produced on the
perfect competition,
but more than we produced under monopoly.
And consequently prices are
going to go the other way, right?
And consequently prices are going
to be highest on the monopoly.
Lowest under competition. I'm somewhere
in between in this corner situation.
All right, so from the point of view
of, of point of view of the producers,
this corner equilibrium
is worse than monopoly,
but better than perfect competition and
but what have you have the rest of us,
the consumers,
this corner quantity is worse
than perfect competition,
but better than monopoly.
All right there he ride on that being,
if that producing Coca Cola and you
have any kind of concern for your teeth,
maybe you can, maybe you shouldn't
produce so much. Anyway. All right,
so so far what we've done is we've
looked at this classic, if I had,
it's not the most exciting
game in the world,
but it he'll classic and the application
of Game Theory to imperfect competition.
Next time, I'm actually going
to take us a bit further,
but I'm going to leave this game behind
and look at other ways in which we can
study imperfect competition
using game theory.